hey guys Pete here it's gonna be my twin
peek season 3 part 16 top moments recap
spoiler warning this will ruin the
episode completely if you watch this and
you haven't seen it yet so don't watch
if you haven't watched part 16 so what
an episode this was it's kind of crazy
when you think about it because it was
non-stop action for the most part but
really not that much happen I mean it if
you compare it to some of the other
really exciting episodes I mean not that
much different things actually happen
the things that ever happened that they
were really big and it was fantastic but
yeah there isn't a lot of different
stuff it was the the number of
individual storylines has been
compressed and I think it's a really
nice setup for the ending so the first
big moment for sure was evil coop and
Richard horn we don't exactly get that
father-son talk that we hoped for but we
do get a end to Richard's storyline evil
coop tells him he has coordinates he has
three different two are the same and
they both lead them to this rock in the
field somewhere he has Richard go and
look Jerry Horne comes out of the woods
at the right time to see this all go
down although he can't really work the
binoculars so it's not entirely clear if
he understood who was there or not but
sure enough Richard goes up onto the
rock to the place where he was led most
likely by Phillip Jeffries and he gets
zapped and is disappeared from the earth
as far as we can tell and the next big
moment was as Koopas walking away he
says goodbye my son
which I guess doesn't really explain
anything except for that he's probably
his dad we also see evil coupe try to
send a text it doesn't send right away
but it's just a smiley face emoticon and
it says all in capital letters we assume
that he sent it to Diane and later on we
have that verified Dougy coupe who we
suspect is probably the real coupe again
is in a coma at the hospital we see Jani
E and sunny Jim there Bushnell show
and then eventually the mitchum brothers
with candy and crew are all in the room
the Mitchum's give food to the family
and then head off over to their house
where we know that Hutchins shantel are
posted up waiting for dougie to come
back so they can kill him we also know
that the FBI has stopped by and found
out no one was home and that they left
behind Wilson to watch over to see
what's happening this leads to a
colossal moment when a random neighbor
of Jani Ian Dougie's shows up and he
doesn't like where Hutchins shantel or
parked they don't back down in light of
the situation and it ends up in a
shootout where he ends up killing them
both and so no more Cheetos no more
banter no more Hutchins shantel at all
it was a pretty good closing scene for
these two both actors did a great job of
playing disaffected killers
professionals if you will and it's kind
of fitting because we saw how good they
were at what they did in planning things
out and it would be this kind of thing
that would take them out in the end the
Mitchell brothers were also there and it
was hilarious to me whenever they were
talking and you know they're watching
this guy spray the band that those two
were in and Rodney just sort of looks
over at Bradley and it's like people are
under a lot of stress yeah it's just
perfect you know and I mean these guys
are hardened gangsters who are dropping
off food at their friend Dougie's house
because they know his family's going
through a hard time it was just pretty
perfect all the way around then we go
back to the hospital for the payoff that
everybody's been waiting for Jani E and
sonny jim go off to the bathroom
bushnell hears a noise and sort of gets
distracted and leaves the room and mike
shows up and we finally see agent Cooper
wake up and whenever he says you're
awake he says 100% and things are back
to normal
finally just at the end now Mike warns
him that the other guy evil coupe hasn't
gone back in and it sees that agent
Cooper understood what was going on even
though he wasn't able to act normally
whenever he was with this situation like
he seems to understand what's going on
he takes some hair and he gives it to
Mike and tells him he needs another seed
is what I took it as I mean he could
have said he needs another doppelganger
but I'm not really sure to me it seemed
like he was talking about the little
golden orb but he called a seed and that
he needed another one of those Bushnell
comes back and we get our first real
agent Cooper experienced in 25 years and
it's pretty awesome he thanks him for
his help he tells him he's a good man he
borrows his gun tells them to call the
Mitchum's they're waiting on call to get
a jet their jet gassed up and ready to
go to Spokane and then agent Cooper goes
outside gets in the car and it's pretty
it's pretty awesome I mean it was cool
to see the family but you kind of had
that aching feeling like what's gonna
happen to Janie and sunny Jim now that
this has gone down so it was a really
nice kind of thing like you know you're
really excited that Cooper's back but
you're also kind of like feeling for
these family that you've known who
literally did take care of him for the
last 15 weeks of us viewing it's kind of
too fast in a way but that's what we're
just gonna have to live with that
because we've got two hours to go and
I'm hoping it'll basically be dia Dale
Cooper fast from that point on I mean I
was personally completely floored when
the Twin Peaks theme music started to
play and he started to talk I know a lot
of people were going crazy waiting for
this to happen but I think it was pretty
damn satisfying at the end of the day as
they're driving off he explains where
they're going after a heartfelt goodbye
like a legitimate heartfelt goodbye with
sunny Jim and Janie he we really don't
know how that's gonna end up I mean he
tells them that he loves them and thanks
them we can see that their hearts are
breaking and even though he tells them
that he'll be back
I don't really know that's what we're
supposed to assume or not but there was
another good scene in the car whenever
he's talking to Bradley and Rodney he
tells them that he's been witness to the
fact that they have hearts of gold and
typical Agent Dale Cooper fashion and he
explains that they're going off to
Washington
and that everybody's going along so
that's all really good in my book as far
as I'm concerned the next big thing that
happens is when we did see Gordon
earlier he was kind of monitoring what
was going on and then we get a scene of
Diane who gets the text message and it's
almost like she goes haywire we can't
really tell what's going on she's
clearly stressed out though she goes
upstairs she's standing outside Gordon
tells her to come in and then she starts
to explain that night when she last saw
Cooper we find out that she did actually
get raped by evil koo and then she says
that he took her to a gas station but it
kind of sounded like the convenience
store and then things started to get
mixed up and she starts to freak out and
eventually she pulls a gun but Tammy and
Albert are ready and they shoot her and
she disappears only to ream aterial eyes
later in front of Mike inside the Red
Room where he says the same thing he
said to dougie that you've been
manufactured and the same things happens
we see the golden seed oh the golden
ball come out and what was great about
Dianne's was is that instead of just
sitting there quietly like dougie did
she got one last [ __ ] you in there
before it was all said and done so she
did get that text we don't really
understand how that works
Tammy did point out the idea that she
was a Tulpa that TOPAS were real she
disappeared just like we heard about the
other case case number one and the blue
rose task force so I don't know if we're
gonna learn any more about that or not I
mean it was pretty bizarre and she
wasn't wearing the ring like the other
ones were so I don't know at the end of
the day we found out that evil coupe has
been busy in the last 25 years and it
seems that most of what he was busy with
was staying out of the Black Lodge so I
don't know for any closer to
understanding what the nature of evil
coupe is like what he is planning for
for the endgame but we can see that he
is influential on all the stories that
we've been sort of watching on the
outside of this thing we finally see
Eddie Vedder playing at the Roadhouse he
plays the song
the sand that was released before the
season started it kind of had a feeling
like is this gonna be the end are you
kidding me but then we see Audrey walk
in and this seems like a big reveal of
her not actually being somewhere else
until after he's done playing the emcee
comes back out and he just says Audrey's
dance at the old music from the early
scene of her you know isn't this music
too dreamy and the dance all of that the
big callback to the you know the early
part of this entire franchise is going
on and we know that can't be real or we
think it can't be real and then we hear
someone come into the place scream
that's my wife run over start a fight
and Audrey stops dancing runs over to
Charlie and says get me out of here and
she ends up in a white room staring into
a mirror and this all seems that we hear
them the electrical sounds as well so
this all seems to go back to evil coupe
as well although we don't know for sure
but it also talks about what I was
saying in my what's up with Audrey video
it seems like she is stuck somewhere
else so I don't know if we have any more
clarification about anything about what
that is by seeing her in a white room
with a mirror but she's clearly stuck in
some other kind of plane of existence
and it's probably related directly to
evil coupe and since we heard him say
that Richard was his son well you can
get that there's connection there and
that's pretty much it for the big
moments there were some great little
bits of dialogue I loved it whenever
candy came out with the they do they
really do whenever coop was talking
about the golden hearts classic dick
Agent Dale Cooper whenever Bushnell
asked him about the FBI and he turns
around and says I am the FBI Chantel and
Hutch was really funny little back and
forth they had there and the guy with
the car was crazy like that was a really
out there kind of thing that happened so
yeah you know the drill like the video
if you enjoyed it there'll be more to
come this week make sure you subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
turn on notifications
follow me on Twitter leave some comments
let me know what you guys are thinking
Dale is back agent Cooper's back and we
only have two hours left so I can't wait
to see what happens thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon